¿Para qué sirve compromís?
Oiga, danba usted votos de investidura a cambio de nada,
tan fieros para pedir 1 puesto de segundón.
Bueno, perdón, señor marza,
de tercerón en la lista de Yolanda Díaz.
Oiga, y tan dóciles
para traer 1 sola inversión a la Comunidad Valenciana,
ni 1 tramo de nada,
ni 1 ampliación de nefroestructura,
de nada.
Los únicos proyectos que pueden venir a Valencia,
como es algo del trasvase o el Puerto de Valencia.
Ustedes en contra, oiga,
si fuera por compromís,
es que no ha existido el gobierno de España
ni 1 ni 1 sola factura.
¿Me puede decir para qué nos sirve
compromís a los ciudadanos de la Comunidad Valenciana?
¿Financiación? No nos ha traído el fondo de de transición,
fondo de nivelación,
no nos ha traído el túnel de Alfafar.
No, oiga,
¿para qué sirve compromís? Dígamelo,
¿a qué nos sirve aquí?